let me pull the story we have uh on that
note from the daily mail ron desantis
signs law banning abortion after 15
weeks republican says we are here to
defend those who can't defend themselves
so we also have another bill here this
is from uh that's the wrong story here
we go kentucky lawmakers override
governor beshear's vetoes on abortion
fairness and women's sports we're seeing
across the country
many states are just saying outright roe
v wade is no longer relevant they're
just passing the laws i think oklahoma
made that bill which outright makes
abortion a felony well but colorado
passed a law or colorado's governor
passed a law this week or proposed a law
uh that says abortion all the way up
until the moment of birth which also
says that roe v wade doesn't matter
right because roe v wade
disallows that very same concept so on
both sides but
at both political extremes roe v wade
because roe v wade was a nonsensical
ruling in the first place it can't
actually play out consistently so nobody
does you want to break down roe v wade
for us i don't think we've actually ever
actually got into the nitty-gritty well
i i don't have my magnifying glass to
find the emanations of the penumbras
that entails this constitutional right
but it's just it's just a nonsense
decision that came out in 1973 that said
because of a vague generalized right to
privacy and the vague emanations and the
penumbras abortions nowhere in the text
and if it is anywhere in the text it's
in the 14th amendment and it prohibits
abortion but because we don't want to
deal with it anymore it created this
fictional right to an abortion and ever
since then the pro-life movement's only
grown stronger you had it come back
again in 1992 with planned parenthood v
casey which created a different
justification for abortion because again
as jeremy said it's not in the text and
so you you come up with this new
justification which focuses more on the
trimesters and viability and that
doesn't make any sense because with new
technology babies are now viable at a
much earlier stage and so
right now just to put on my nostradamus
hat and predict the future here uh
we we do seem to be at the first spot
since roe versus wade where the court
i think is likely to overrule roe and
the reason i think they're likely is
because
from the oral arguments
one you've already got clarence thomas
you've already got alito it seems like
you got kavanagh it seems like you got
barrett it seems like you got gorsuch
there you go 5'4 you don't even have
john roberts yet if roberts joins the
quartz libs and it's 5'4 clarence thomas
writes the decision and man that
decision is going to be good okay so i
think roberts to preserve the integrity
and legitimacy of the court and actually
to water down as much as he can the way
that they would overrule row i think he
has to join the conservatives so then
you get a 6-3 decision
this can't be right bill maher said that
republicans didn't want any black
supreme court justices how could you how
could you tell me it's like the only one
we like is the black guy
this concerns me if i think if they do
try to make abortion illegal that you're
going to see a large uptick in
miscarriages and what i mean by that is
women accidentally falling over on
purpose and landing on their stomachs
until the baby's dead uh
it's terrifying i just don't see i don't
think you can ever stop women from
killing a child they don't want you you
can't do some numbers yeah and i don't
think that's bad people are like you
want women going into back alleys and
putting their lives at risk yeah
but by the way but that's actually
mythical
risk
you can break this down if you want to
also overturning road doesn't make
abortion illegal this is this is the
great lie of the left is oh they're
going to overturn roe and no woman will
be able to get an abortion if only but
that's not actually what will happen
what happens when they overturn roe is
it it basically
becomes a state's rights issue again and
as you can see between the laws in
florida and the laws in colorado
federalism is alive and well in this
country even 15 weeks
puts you just on average with the most
liberal democracies in europe no one
allows abortion the way that we allow in
this country no one except the chinese
and the north koreans canadians yeah and
then those three allows abortion the way
that we do in this country uh so to push
it back to the states is an enormous
victory in fact the democrats are saying
right now that while they still control
the house and the senate and the
presidency they should ensconce abortion
in federal law so that even if roe is
overturned by the court in june uh you
still won't be able to do anything about
abortion unfortunately i don't think
they have the votes in the senate
unfortunately i don't think they have
to accomplish and on this point of the
back alley abortions this is one of the
biggest lies from the abortion movement
it's literally a lie it's a lie i mean
so one of the guys who came up with the
lie dr bernard nathanson one of the
founders of narow he he came out and he
said five thousand women a year at least
some people say twenty thirty thousand
women a year died from back alley
abortions before row he admitted they
just made up the number we actually have
the number the government kept the
statistics in 1972 the year before roe
vs wade was decided 39 women died from
back alley abortions illegal ones 24
women died from legal abortions and
what's even crazier is when you look at
the breakdown of states where abortion
was legal versus illegal
your likelihood of dying in an abortion
was basically the same whether it was
legal or illegal that was in the early
70s it would be obviously much lower now
yeah so we actually did an educational
breakdown of this on it for a freedom
tunes video a couple of years ago but
basically in the 1930s you had something
like a bit over 2 000 women who had died
and been counted statistically as deaths
from abortions and miscarriages but that
number decreased significantly after the
advent of the widespread availability of
penicillin it was an issue of women not
getting antibiotics
take a look at this comic uh i saw this
recently i think as i saw earlier today
on twitter but uh can we can we pull
that up there you go
red states to blue states the next
refugees women women what they what they
fail to ever bring
up in this conversation is how many
women are pro-life
i believe the majority of pro-life
people in the country are females yes
and this is huge because the left never
got the cultural shift that they wanted
after roe v wade so as you mentioned 60
million unborn children have died of
course that's not enough for them they
would rather that number was much higher
and when you look at how long ago the
supreme court made its decision on
the question of homosexuality that was
what about 10 years ago and look where
our culture is now i mean we've taken
that almost to its furthest extreme but
not quite yet it's very unpopular to say
anything against gay marriage it seems a
large population a large percentage of
the population believes in it but if you
look at the abortion decision what this
is 50 years ago and still half of the
population is adamantly against it i
bring this up with uh new york there
they recognize 31 different genders but
by law they recognize any possible
gender and gender identity is defined as
effect essentially self-expression
so
when the when when the arguments first
come for uh gender identity protections
everybody says we know what this means
and what the intent is there's a famous
story about um when they outlawed public
drinking in new york that one of the you
know city council members or whatever
said let this law never be construed to
say a construction worker can't enjoy a
beer with his lunch sure enough that's
exactly what it means today yeah so in
new york when they say we want to
protect trans people we all say we
totally understand that we don't want
people to be discriminated against and
then what happens is the law is tested
and someone will say it says
self-expression that's how you defined
it i hereby challenge this and say my
self-expression is that i can wear a
clown costume into work or or a fursuit
or something you know there's an
abortion tie in here too one of the main
drivers of transgenderism in the culture
is that second abortion case planned
parenthood v casey in which the romantic
poet of the court anthony kennedy said
that at the heart of liberty
is the ability to define our own concept
of existence of the mystery of life
scalia mocked it as the sweet mystery of
life passage
you you do i i don't even have to say
this
you don't have the right to define your
own concept of existence no one has that
right it you you don't have the ability
to do that either you have a
responsibility to accept reality and
live in reality but but if if kennedy
grants you that well then it's just
self-expression i i disagree i disagree
uh this is my trailer my rules from now
on you will address me as god king well
also
there can be only one capital capital
okay but but in all seriousness i mean
if you're extremely wealthy you know
elon musk or jeff bezos can go to their
company and say from now on you must
address me as this and i suppose if
you're powerful enough you can make
people do what you want them to do mad
king right i mean yeah yeah yeah that's
right it's also bizarre that like a
legal scholar could determine that the
law is about self-invention isn't it the
exact opposite it's about placing
constraints on people you know i think i
think you can define reality the way you
want but you're subject to the
consequences you can say
that there's a rock right there and i
can go hit the rock but it's tim it
turns out and i'm going to suffer mad
but i might still psychotically have to
find it improperly that's still my right
as a you know this is my big problem
with the whole conversation about
about transhumanity at the moment which
is if um if a man says that he's a woman
he legally is a woman
if a man says that he's a carrot and i
eat him they still put me in prison it's
awful
discrimination
a better example is the man who uh filed
a challenge to his age and said if if
biology is self-identity then i can
identify as younger and they said no you
can't do that and i and so i've talked
talked about this before where i you
know i talked to several civil rights
attorneys in new york about the limits
of this and they said that the judiciary
exists to interpret the law if you tried
to say pull a fast one or challenge to
to absurdity they'll throw you out i i
completely reject
that that notion that
you could be a biological male six foot
three 200 220 pounds
you know muscular and identify as a
woman put on a dress go to a court and
the judge is not allowed to to mock you
the judge must accept you under the law
but if you put on a fursuit
under the same exact provisions in the
law you are protected that the clothing
you wear cannot be discriminated the
name you choose so i am vulciferon
herald of the winter mists this is my my
identity a judge can laugh at you then
i understand there is a distinction the
argument is that in modern culture we
recognize transgenderism as a legitimate
issue and we mock furries but i reject
the premise because eventually what we
see is people will test the limits of
the law and eventually in one generation
or two a judge will say it does say that
who am i who am i to say test the limits
of not only the law but reason itself
like i i think of myself as a magnetic
being for instance not everyone i say
that about you all the time thank you so
much for you as well not everyone has to
agree with me on a daily basis and if i
stray too far from reality's observation
of what i am they're going to think i'm
a psychopath and put me in like a psych
ward so you have you can self-identify
however you want but you cannot bend
reality i don't know if there's an
objection but how do you how do you do
it then in practice is my because peop
this is seems to be the middle ground
that people try to find is look i don't
care how you i self-identify in your own
mind but just don't make me participate
in it but the whole point of identity is
so that you can be identified so
we live in a society we live in a
political community
how on earth can you unless you're just
doing it in your basement at night
yelling to nobody how can you have that
right to a delusional identity and not
infringe on my right to reality i mean i
i deferred jesus christ i believe he was
a real man and he truly believed that
god was flown through him which it was
and people did not like it and he was
like well i have a choice to make i can
either denounce this and pretend like
i'm not or i can be honest and let
reality do what it will with me and
depending on how truly you believe it
you have to make that decision but but
yeah but the premise there is he jesus
is god is god we were told i was told i
don't believe that i don't know him but
yeah i think he was you should know that
that was a very trump answer that was a
very i was told that i was given that a
lot of people quite frankly
one of the best um i just want to
mention i just want to make this point
about uh you know this this sort of self
invention and coming up with your own
identity my only question is to even get
to that place how much time do you have
to spend just thinking about yourself no
no already really obnoxious there are
many people who uh you know i can't
remember who told us the story that
someone in their class kept changing
their identity they didn't know in one
week they're this is who i am then a
week later they know my name's owen now
the next week there no it's clyde and
it's just like if
if it's
if there's no identity then it can be
anything at any time and there's no
legal definition there's no no legal
distinction not to just be not to get
too theological here fellas but isn't
look teenagers do that all the time
right teenagers that's sort of the
definition of being 13 years old as you
try on new identities all that i'm goth
now i'm a rocker or whatever uh and it's
because they're immature and juvenile
and they're coming to some concept of
who they are
at the burning bush
god tells moses my name is i am i am
that i am
that's a name he's saying i am being
itself
and
your identity must be in me for you to
make any sense i am the divine logic of
the universe i am being
when you find your identity in
i am
things make sense
when you ignore that and turn away from
i am at all times throughout every
society in all of human history things
start to go pretty kooky and you're left
with a pathetic question which is who am
i changes by the day i want to go back
to abortion real quick because i'm
thinking about this here i am
you know surrounded by more religious
individuals who are much more staunchly
pro-life
and uh i've always so be careful right
well i've always said i was pro-choice
and i think one of the issues is that
when you actually break down the the
absolute nuance of the argument well
then it's like what does pro-choice and
pro-life really mean and i think the
pro-choice people typically do not
understand or there's not enough
complexity in the argument so for
instance we were talking with matt walsh
he argued that abortion is the
intentional act of killing a child and
i'm like right i think that's wrong
but i think there are circumstances
where a medical procedure would be done
that would remove a baby from a mother
and that's where the nuance comes in so
ultimately the conclusion was if you
have to do something for the sake of the
mother
that would result in the the the child
being removed you just don't try to kill
the child and i said interesting i don't
think the pro-choice left understands
the right's position on that i think
they
you know first of all there's a real
problem with the left's argument on
pro-choice in that it is a scientific
fact that life begins at conception and
any argument otherwise is illogical it
makes literally no sense if you want to
get to an authoritarian libertarian
argument on medical choices for private
individuals that's where i'm kind of at
but then the argument never actually
addresses the true stance that that you
guys might have or that um that matt
walsh brought up in that oh yeah
absolutely do the procedure to save the
mother's life and try and save the baby
too and i'm like well yeah of course oh
you're saying they shouldn't just kill
the baby afterwards well i agree with
that
i don't think most pro-choice people
understand that's what you're saying i
don't think they understand much of
anything about pro-life and i'm not
saying that to be a jerk i i was
pro-abortion for 10 years bro in my
teenage years i pro-abortion this was
during his goth phase it was during my
goth rocker phase no pro-choice
pro-aztec i guess i would have said
pro-choice but i mean i grew up in new
york surrounded by liberals i went to a
very liberal college and i just didn't
i just thought conservatives wanted to
control women's bodies i actually that's
all i knew and so i thought i can't i'll
cut taxes but i don't want to i don't
promise to be cool man what happened
i was smoking doobies and stuff i was
like elon musk uh but were you like
hold on some like elon musk and then i
had a conversation with it with a woman
bioethicist and i made all these stupid
utilitarian arguments as to well you
know all the freakonomics arguments well
abortion it stops overpopulation and uh
it lowers all these sorts of social
pathologies and she said oh okay michael
so which one of your arguments for you
know lowering uh crime and welfare
dependency which one of your arguments
is is not an argument for killing uh
young black men in inner cities you're
just making all it's the same argument
right and i thought oh yikes i don't
like that and and i thought about it
more deeply and i thought i realized oh
they're not just evil people trying to
control women's bodies
maybe they maybe there's actually to
this something to this idea that a
baby's a baby and we shouldn't kill it
you know i said it's a scientific fact
that life begins a conception and uh i
just have never understood any logic in
any circumstance even when i wasn't
listening to more pro-life nuanced
arguments
that
you know i think i think was it vosh who
said
when when he was asked by charlie kirk
when does life begin says i don't know
sometime after birth i think that's what
he said then i'm like well that can't
make sense i think of it as life
beginning at conception but at what
point is it a human ah
well it's not a giraffe wait that's not
a platform it is a human life the real
question is when is it unsold
and the answer is we don't know it is it
is possible
that we it is possible that we could
discover uh that life does not begin at
conception i know a lot of people not
i'm sorry not that life does not begin
at conception which of course it does
not that human life doesn't begin to
conception which of course that it does
uh of course it does but that
the installment of a of a child does not
begin at conception the bible is not
clear about this there's an argument for
you know wrestling in the womb and we
like some pro-life likes to use that uh
but there's also the breath of life i
mean there are real questions about
to the extent that it is unknown though
what are we left with we're left with
the things that we do know that life
begins at conception that the life
conceived is a human life
that's what we can measure that's what
we can know that's where we have to
actually make our decision and to the
extent that those things are knowable
and that we do know them in my view
therefore we're left with no other
conclusion but to protect that life you
know that's a good point jeremy and it
raises the question of all right so how
certain are you how what are you willing
to risk you're three percent sure that
you're going to kill 60 million babies
right but there's also sometimes you'll
hear the pro choice pro-abortion people
say well in the christian tradition they
actually had carveouts for some
abortions and they always cite saint
thomas aquinas who was very very
important doctor of the church and
thomas aquinas it seems at least at
first glance to be a little unclear on
this question between
what he considers to be you know the
first step of the baby being made there
is some period of time before the baby
is unsold but it's a it's based on
really ignorance of thomas aquinas
because aquinas is using aristotle's
physics he's using aristotle's
understanding of biology not his fault
not aristotle's fault they didn't have
modern sonograms and so what they
believed was that the sperm acted on the
blood and produced a vegetative soul but
there wasn't really anything even
resembling life until the quickening and
you had this distinct human being and we
just we just know now that isn't true we
know that the sperm and the egg come
together they cease to be what they were
and they become a unique human life and
they're growing and so it's it's no
knock on aquinas or aristotle but by
their own logic
life starts pretty much just right at
concern and also i will i if i'm not
mistaken the official position of the
catholic church is that the the the um
person isn't sold that fertilization
the heartbeat personally because that's
when the magnetic field begins to become
produced
it's it's i think jeremy hit the nail on
the head you know
we we're left with what we know life
begins to continue and and
every argument i've ever heard and i
welcome any you know uh more
pro-abortion pro-left whatever
pro-choice whatever they want to say to
have this discussion because you know i
do feel it's like here's a here's a
pro-choice you know onslaught
essentially i'm pro-life onslaught um
scientifically just what is life a
unique set of dna and i've heard all the
arguments and ultimately you know you
say um you know you mentioned you know
when does it i can't remember when can
you discern that it's a human well so
you know the argument's been made a
million times if a person is brain dead
is it still a person it's a life well of
course it is and so there's the question
of how many grains of sand make a heap
sure but there's still sand there the
process of creating the heap started
when you began trickling sand you know
onto the ground if we want to say what
point has become a person
sure at what point is it a human life
since the beginning when the process
begins to create the human life i like
the unsold question um if you look up
the human magnetic field taurus you see
this that the heartbeat itself is
producing in a magnetic field around the
human body i think that that magnetic
field's interaction with the earth's
magnetic field and maybe the solar
magnetic field and even the galactic is
producing this god consciousness but but
isn't the soul
metaphysical meaning so magnetic forces
are acting on the physical world but
isn't the soul in order for it to be the
soul and not to be the body doesn't it
have to not be physical
it has to be
i say of the soul that it's the
uh the the intersection of the
transcendent and the material so to the
extent that you're describing
the material perhaps expression of the
soul that might very well be true i'd be
curious if the proto-heartbeat produces
a magnetic field which to our current
question would be a really important one
because you know the cells begin
pulsating as a heartbeat before the
heart is actually formed in utero which
is part of the part of the whole kind of
conflict about heartbeat laws right is
what is actually the heartbeat but i i
think your magnetic field thing is
actually really fascinating and we
should look and see if there's if the
proto-heartbeat
i really don't feel like pro-choice
exists anymore and i think it's it's
become a shield for what is overtly
pro-abortion
the reason is i grew up um with a family
that said abortion was wrong
but there are circumstances where it's
not the position of the government to
intervene in a private medical practice
and it becomes scary in certain
circumstances but uh uh
we were a pro-choice family we voted
democrat every step of the way yeah and
the conversation was always it's a
terrible thing that exists but
and and nowadays that's not even the
argument
the argument is women who cares lena
dunham said she wished she had one safe
legal and rare remember all that back in
the al gore days not that long ago not
that long ago and this is this this is
what's been happening now it's shout
your abortion right yeah exactly and and
and you get an abortion and you get one
and lena dunham said she wished she had
one and she was like you know i do all
this advocacy and i just feel bad
because i didn't and i'm just like did
you see this tweet the other day this
woman tweets out a cake yes and it was
the cake said it's a boy and then she
crossed out the y and wrote urshan and
it seems like this was legit and she
said look i i just had my abortion and
abor abortion is a really traumatic
thing to have and it's why you got to
surround yourself with love and
friendship all the time and celebrate it
and the question of course that
naturally follows is
why is it traumatic yeah yeah if it's if
it's something to be celebrated what's
so traumatic about it well kind of like
working out is traumatic to the muscles
literally like you're inducing trauma so
it can regrow stronger
yeah well i don't think this the baby
regrows stronger right i mean what if if
she's speaking about it she's speaking
about it emotionally right that it
creates a trauma is is the idea that the
abortion is an edifying thing and
therefore we should have a lot of them
to get much stronger
that's right this is a great
conversation it's philosophical it's
religious it's legal i want to focus
back on the legal though just for a
minute because a lot of people listening
now know that the court is going to make
a decision in june and they may not know
exactly where they are on some of these
philosophical questions uh they may be
you know persuaded by the catholic view
they may be persuaded by the pro-choice
view uh or or um
the magnetic field the magnetic field oh
yeah i can go deep on that but but the
legal question is what's before us and
what the left likes to do in these
moments is to get people to
hyperventilate with all these
hyperbolic kind of statements about
what's going to occur so just i think
the key things i would want people to
leave with are
overturning roe v wade does not make
abortion illegal
overturning roe v wade gives the states
the right to make abortion illegal and i
doubt that very many states would do it
yeah i doubt that very many i doubt that
very many even conservative states would
go all the way to saying that abortion
must be illegal in all cases i think
that the most likely thing is that
you'll see a radicalization on the in in
blue states where we where we basically
get rid of all the constraints of roe v
wade and casey on viability and other
sorts of standards and you can
essentially kill babies after birth
which is actually a thing that happens i
think on the other hand you'll have a
few states that outlaw
abortion i think you'll have many states
that take up more of a european standard
which would at least reduce the most
horrific instances of abortion where
babies who can actually feel are being
dismembered so that they can be
extracted from their mothers and
and in that world
the cartoon tim that you put up with the
refugees
well i think that's
uh
asinine statement that all women are
gonna there actually will be more voting
with your feet there will be a further
kind of balkanization politically of the
country i happen to think that that's a
good thing
i i'm really interesting what i'm really
annoyed by in all of this is that we've
come to the point where in virginia and
in colorado it's it's like a a full-term
baby can be aborted and it's just like
that you know this is why i say life
begins at conception as a fact right
yeah you you can't abort a baby at eight
months because it could be taken out and
just placed on a table and it will live
you're literally just executing it and
they call it an abortion we we you know
as soon as the conception occurs there's
a unique set of dna and that's all you
really need i i accept that if we look
at a single cell on mars and say it's
life we can look at a single cell and
women and say we have life it's it's
it's it's the argument pro-life people
often bring up that the scientific
community says they found single cells
here and is it life but they won't say
the same thing of a human being i i
accept the scientific reality of a
unique set of dna the problem is
as i mentioned with my family growing up
the left's stance now is if you are
pro-choice you are on board with
unfettered access at any point to some
of the most disgusting procedures of
killing babies and i'm not talking about
the the the right wing perspective of
you know on day two of you know a
fertilized egg you're killing a baby i'm
saying
imagine
that you are a a democrat and the baby
is or uh gaz no he would deliver the
babies and then kill them there's a guy
right now cesare santangelo
the story just broke he's done this 200
at least hundreds of babies probably
thousands of babies we're talking full
term or nearly full term in some cases
almost certainly were actually born
first and then he's killing them he's
the worst serial killer in america and
no one wants to say his name just like
gosnell because the process of abortion
for uh possible late term abortions is
they just kill the baby which could
survive on its own that's right and and
the other thing is and michael alluded
to this technology is part of this
conversation yeah because the the age of
viability gets younger and younger and
younger as we get better and better and
better at medicine and medical
procedures it's very conceivable that
one day you'll be able to extract a
zygote out from a woman and put it in
some sort of pod and raise it
up until you know it's able to
breathe on its own as a
and get a driver's license
so the question is like even if
viability is your standard what does
viability mean and they'll say well
viability means when it can survive on
its own
two-year-olds can't survive on their own
right
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time